en route vers les extrêmes à la
recherche de plus remarquables du plus
grand du plus chaud n'est plus froids ou
du plus loin les records de l'univers
premier record la terre abrite le plus
grand organisme vivant du système
solaire au nord-est de l'australie
le corail de la grande barrière de
corail
en dehors de celui là notre planète est
pauvre en record bien sûr ou l'inde
rejoint l'asie s'élèvent les sommets de
l'himalaya
à huit mille huit cents mètres de haut
c'est le plus haut sommet de la terre
hélas la forte gravité de notre planète
limite la taille des montagnes un géant
terrestre de 9 km de haut ne serait
qu'une colline sur mars ce sommet sur
mars est trois fois plus élevée que
l'everest
même notre lune est modeste
ganymède une lune de jupiter est le plus
gros satellite du système solaire de la
taille d'une planète plus gros même que
pluton et mercure
la fierté de l'amérique
le grand canyon ses parois les plus
hautes se dresse à 1600 mètres sur
miranda un satellite glacé d'uranus
certaines falaise mesure près de 20
kilomètres de haut
la terre n'a qu'un satellites la lune
saturne une planète géante à des
milliards de petits satellites
ailleurs s'élèvent des volcans plus
grand que le texas et des geysers plus
haut que l'everest
et des orages qui ferait s'envoler la
terre comme un ballon
la température la plus haute jamais
enregistré sur terre et de 58 degrés en
libye c'est chaud mais ce n'est rien
comparé à la source de cette chaleur le
soleil
le soleil est une étoile une chaudière
nucléaire
c'est l'endroit le plus chaud du système
solaire au coeur du soleil à l'endroit
de la fusion la température est de 15
millions de degrés pourtant à la surface
sa température n'est plus que de 6 mille
degrés et dans une tache solaire
seulement de 4500 degrés
mais sans que personne ne sache encore
pourquoi les températures s'élèvent dans
l'atmosphère solaire dans la couronne
elle grimpe à plus de 2 millions de
degrés
mercure à peine plus grande que notre
lune et la planète la plus proche du
soleil
bien qu'elles soient brûlées et irradié
mercure n'est pas la planète plus chaude
ce qui a de quoi surprendre car deux
jours les températures y dépasse les 400
degrés nous savons peu de choses sur
mercure et les seules photos détaillées
dont nous disposons date des années 70
elle montre un monde ancien et aride
sans air et creusé de nombreux cratères
pourquoi autant de cratères à cause du
soleil bien sûr comme un aimant sa forte
gravité attire des débris de l'espace
hélas pour mercure elle est sur la
trajectoire
il reçoit de nombreux projectiles
le lever du soleil sur mercure et le
plus étrange du système solaire à
certains endroits le soleil semble
rebondir comme un ballon ceci est dû à
la vitesse de rotation particulière de
mercure ainsi qu à l'excentricité de son
orbite
à peine le soleil se couche il doit se
lever à nouveau
voici une autre énigme en observant
grâce à des radars mercure trop proches
du soleil pour être nettement visible
dans le domaine optique
des astronomes ont découvert des taches
brillante aux pôles il pense il s'agit
de glace de la glace si près du soleil
c'est possible car la nuit les
températures dégringolent en dessous de
moins 100 70 degrés les paul est en
plongée dans une obscurité permanente la
glace d'anciennes comet a pu survivre
paradoxalement nous devons aller loin du
soleil pour trouver la planète la plus
chaude venus jumelle de la terre par la
taille détient le record de chaleur
venus est un enfer où la chaleur du
soleil se retrouve piégé par une
atmosphère 90 fois plus dense que celle
de la terre où que vous alliez de jour
comme de nuit la température est
constante 450°
oh
on
l'endroit le plus froid de la terre et
l'antarctique
oh
non
la température la plus basse jamais
enregistrée sur ce continent est moins
55 degrés
mais l'endroit le plus froid du système
solaire se trouve ailleurs
les planètes extérieures et le satellite
miranda miranda n'est pas seulement
couvertes de glace
elle est formée de glace et pourtant il
existe un endroit encore plus froid
pluton suivant une vaste orbite
elliptique pluton et la planète la plus
éloignée du soleil
c'est également la plus petite et la
moins bien connues
pourtant il existe un endroit encore
plus froid c'est ici que les astronomes
ont enregistré les températures les plus
basses à ce jour triton un satellite de
neptune les températures ne dépassent
pas moins 180 degrés en dessous de zéro
mais sur la face ensoleillée de prix
dont les températures sont assez chaude
pour entretenir un délicat système
climatique et envoyer des jeunes zerbaz
up à plus de 12 km dans l'atmosphère
avait milliard de kilomètres des boules
de glace ont été détectés et se sont
peut-être elles qui détiennent le record
de froid au qu'une sonde ne les a encore
atteinte
mais on pense que leur température est
d'environ 230 degrés en dessous de zéro
un autre concours est ouvert quel corps
du système solaire a reçu le plus gros
projectiles proportionnellement à sa
taille
quand les illustrateurs du 19e siècle
représentait la lune il imagine l
immense montagne
il s'inspirait de la géologie de la
terre des arêtes et des crevasses comme
l'ont découvert les astronautes
américains
la réalité est moins escarpé
il y à des sommets plus élevé que
l'everest et les cratères immense mais
il semble arrondies et aplatit en fait
c'est parce que la lune et d'une petite
planète il n'est pas nécessaire de
s'éloigner de beaucoup pour que les
reliefs disparaissent derrière l'horizon
pour dans ce cratère est impressionnant
c'est la mer orientale
d'un diamètre de 920 kilomètres mercure
porte la trace d'un impact semblables
colorier ici c'est le bassin de la
chaleur il mesure 1280 km de diamètre et
pourtant ce n'est pas le plus grand le
satellite calysto de jupiter ne remporte
pas le titre non plus malgré un cratère
de 3000 km de diamètre
la coupe revient à me masse un minuscule
satellite de saturne seul cratère ne
mesure que 128 km de diamètre
mais il couvre un tiers du diamètre de
limaces
saturne et ses merveilleuses anneaux
gagne tous les concours de beauté
admirez en gros plan les anneaux sont
formés d'innombrables petits satellites
qui orbite à l'unisson autour de la
grosse planète
formé de roches et glacée ils vont de la
taille d'un grain de sable à la grosseur
d'une maison
les hommes connaissaient ses anneaux
depuis des siècles mais jusqu'à la sonde
voyageurs au début des années 80 les
astronomes pensaient qu'il n'y avait
qu'une demi-douzaine dano en se servant
de l'occultation d'une étoile située
derrière les anneaux voyageant les a
comptés il y à cette bande principales
formes et de centaine d'anneaux on pense
qu'il s'agit de débris de satellite
éclaté et me masse a eu de la chance de
ne pas les rejoindre
si le missile qui a creusé son cratère
avait été plus gros me masse aurait été
pulvérisé
et voici un autre satellite détenteur
d'un record you est l'une des 16 lunes
de jupiter retient captive elio à des
accès de colère
des volcans projette des gaz à une
altitude proche de 300 km et au possède
l'activité volcanique la plus importante
du système solaire
le plus grand volcan et sur mars le mont
olympe est un depuis longtemps
ici mise en valeur par ordinateur il
s'élève de 25 km au dessus des plaines
qui l'entouré couvre presque 270 mille
kilomètres carrés
le mont olympe est l'un des nombreux
énorme volcan de mars reliques d'un
passé agité
ils ont craché des gaz sulfureux dans
une atmosphère alors beaucoup plus dense
qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui dans le
passé mars était une planète
dotée d'un climat à dos et peut-être qui
sait vie
les triples volcan de tard 6 nous
survolons mars
des minces volutes de nuages se cachent
dans les crevasses et les canyon
mars est une planète froide et sans vie
au mieux la température monte à 24
degrés en plaine et est allé compteur
on survole la vallée marineris aussi
longue que la distance qui sépare la
côte est de la côte ouest des états unis
et voilà artias la d3 volcan de tard 6
pavot nice
et un scrabble
des volcans gigantesque une superbe
photo pour l'album surtout encadrés par
les murailles de la vallée marineris
mais pour trouver les murailles les plus
hautes
il faut aller sur miranda
ces murailles de blast mesure 20 mille
mètres de haut la gravité est si faible
que si vous sautez du sommet vous
n'atteindrez pas le fond avant deux
minutes et demie
miranda rosell peut être un futur
paradis pour les skieurs les alpes et
les montagnes rocheuses de demain ce
minuscule satellite est presque
entièrement constitué de glace on dirait
une sphère brisée puis recoller à la va
vite
si vous passez par là uranus vaut la
visite
où se trouve le plus mauvais climat du
système solaire pour avoir un climat il
faut une atmosphère malgré son apparente
tranquillité la planète rouge est une
candidate possible
l'aube sur mars
en 1976 les américains virent d'acquérir
deux sondes spatiales sur la planète
et voilà ce qu'elles ont vu un désert
sans vie rougis par l'oxydé de fer
la température à midi +4 degrés celsius
une atmosphère de gaz carbonique moins
de 1% de celle de la terre
mais elles n'ont pas vu les tempêtes de
poussière qui balaie la surface
des tempêtes si fortes qu'elles peuvent
être filmés de la terre tandis qu'elle
enveloppe mars tout entière des tempêtes
bien différente sont fréquentes sur
terre mais elles n'ont rien
d'extraordinaire même pas les
mystérieuses orages de l'après haute
atmosphère terrestre enregistré
récemment
pour trouver un climat extraordinaire il
faut aller sur une planète géante
quant aux voyageurs a observé saturne
les instruments ont dû le faire à
travers un brouillard qui cachait le
climat
dans ce plan large les bandes de
circulation atmosphérique sont à peine
visibles avec trois des satellites de
saturne les ceintures sont des courants
de nuages soufflant le plus souvent de
l'est autour de la planète
une tache blanche à peine visible dans
le coin supérieur droit
c'est une tempête de la taille de
l'europe
à travers un filtre de fausses couleurs
on voit une autre tempête
c'est la tâche sombre en dessous de la
bande jaune ce gros plans prix d'un
voyageur montre la tempête accompagnée
de deux orages plus petit est ici la
mince traîner ondulante d'un courant
d'altitude comme ceux que l'on trouve
dans l'atmosphère supérieur de la terre
sur saturne ils soufflent à plus de 1600
km heure cinq fois plus vite que sur la
terre
ces images montrent le climat le plus
extrême de saturne une tempête qui ne
souffle qu'une fois tous les 30 ans
cet événement ne se produit que quand
cette urne est le plus proche du soleil
c'est le grand blizzard damaniak à son
maximum
ils entourent l'équateur
plus loin quand voyageurs arrivent à en
vue de neptune le climat se dégrade a
encore
le nuage supérieurs étaient bénins mais
et neptune génère plus de chaleur
qu'elle n'en absorbe
le résultat est un climat dynamique et
des orages cyclonique comme l'oeil du
sorcier est au dessus de l'oeil
cette grande tache sombre est une
tempête la taille de la terre
voyageur a pris une série d'image
successives de cette tâche au tour des
vents soufflent à presque deux mille
kilomètres heure ce sont les plus
rapides du système solaire
mystérieusement la tâche disparu en 1994
certains astronomes pensent que ce
n'était pas une tempête mais le site
d'un impact de météorite une cicatrice
qui s'est refermée
abandonnant les plus grandes tempêtes
nous nous dirigeons vers la plus grande
planète jupiter
jupiter jouit d'un climat brûlant il est
produit par la chaleur même de la
planète
voici la plus grosse de tout les temps
est la grande tache rouge
elle mesure plus de deux fois la taille
de la terre et elle souffle depuis plus
de 350 ans
la tache rouge est un tourbillon de
haute pression mais comment s'est il
formé une banque climatique simulés par
ordinateur montre comment plusieurs
tempêtes se poursuivant au tour de la
planète peuvent finir par se rejoindre
pour ne plus former qu'un seul et même
orages tels que la tâche rouge
l'une des raisons du climat turbulent de
jupiter et la vitesse de rotation de la
planète
ici un jour dure à peine 10 heures la
plus grosse planète à le jour le plus
court
à l'opposé mercure une planète minuscule
tourner si lentement que sa journée dure
les deux tiers de son année sur vénus
une journée dure plus longtemps qu'une
année il faut plus longtemps à venus
pour tourner sur son axe que pour
parcourir son orbite autour du soleil
une journée sur la comète de halley peut
durer sept jours terrestres mais son
année dur les trois quarts d'un siècle
un jour sur notre lune dure un peu plus
de 27 jours terrestres
presque un mois c'est aussi le temps
qu'il faut à la lune pour tourner autour
de notre planète
c'est aussi vrai pour les lunes de
jupiter et pour tous les satellites une
journée sur un satellite correspond à
une révolution autour de la planète mer
ganymède et le plus grand satellite du
système solaire c'est une lune de
jupiter
mesurant presque 5300 km de diamètre
ganymède et plus gros que pluton et
mercure
dactyle est la plus petite planète c'est
un rocher de moins d'un kilomètre et
demi de diamètre qui est en orbite non
pas autour d'une planète mais d'un
astéroïde ida
pluton est la plus petite planète son
diamètre est égale à la moitié de la
distance entre la côte est et la côte
ouest des états unis
pluton voyage avec son compagnon charon
bien sûr la plus grosse planète et
jupiter elle est si grosse que 1300
terre pourrait tenir à l'intérieur
le plus gros corps du système solaire et
le soleil avec 1 million 400 mille
kilomètres de diamètre
il faudrait plus d'un million de terre
pour le remplir
pourtant un minuscule morceau de glace
peut couvrir une distance encore plus
grande quand une comète s'approche du
soleil elle laisse échapper une traînée
de poussières et de gaz qui peut
s'étendre sur près de 100 millions de km
dans l'espace
mais voici la championne du système
solaire quitter notre planète nous fait
l'apprécier davantage notre terre bat
tous les records
la vie a émergé de ces océans un
accident chimique d'une ses produits
nulle part ailleurs
cette vie a engendré la race humaine une
espèce unique dans le développement de
sa pensée le record ultime